and it's nearly everyday this week I
wake up there's something to talk about
no I mean my zombie eyes are totally
because this is a Halloween trailer
video and it's thematic I just woke up
dude but we have a new trailer for
Halloween which is a sequel to Halloween
was gonna be really confusing if you buy
the blu-ray for this and put it next to
the original Halloween movie in your
life you want to watch Halloween or the
sequel Halloween but the trailer starts
out in these two people who I believe
are investigative reporters of some sort
are like we want to talk to Michael
Myers were investigating the guy who
killed three teenagers which is really
interesting it really shows the shift in
the times nowadays it's like he killed
three teenagers he's not worth talking
to or about he's kind of a morbid
thought but it does show how much the
world's changed for the worse yeah but
given the body count the fact that it
was in the 70s the theatricality of the
situation Michael Myers would go down in
infamy if he was real in the 70s so
anyhow these two go to him they're like
Michael I have something to show you
your old mask why they think that was
smart first of all the guy's been caught
he hasn't made a ruckus in about 40
years what are you just trying to stir
the pot just just leave him there
well thing you don't want to do is show
him the mask that might take him back to
the time I was like going hey Dahmer I
got something Cannibal Holocaust
I'll bring the popcorn good just don't
do it so anyhow he breaks that and
Michael Myers is back first order of
business is to kill this lady in a stall
who I believe is the lady who was with
the guy who just showed Michael Myers
his mask he starts freaking around he's
like don't worry I'm a dentist and
everyone gets to see the return of their
favorite mass-murdering senior citizen
how are they gonna take him out today if
he's on nitrates for his heart give them
viagra put him in cardiac arrest it's a
great man once that if you gotta go go
with a smile so now it's gonna be Laurie
Strode and Michael Myers facing off with
every Halloween movie after the first
one being completely scrapped Halloween
- didn't happen Halloween 3 you can
argue it still happened it doesn't do
with Michael Myers the Halloween 4 5 6
Halloween h2o Halloween resurrection the
Rob Zombie Halloween's no it's Halloween
and now the sequel Halloween because has
seen this before is the mind-blowing
thing this is what Halloween h2o was it
was like after a long hiatus Michael
Myers is back and now Laurie Strode will
face him in the true Halloween sequel
and now in this movie it's like after a
long hiatus Michael Myers is back and
now Laurie Strode will face him in the
true Halloween sequel the sensation of
this movie coming out isn't a new
sensation for me if I'm being honest I'm
interested in seeing it but I really do
feel like it's the Halloween name and
the Michael Myers character that's
selling this for me it was any other
trailer where someone comes to a town
wears a mask and starts killing people I
mean like
some years ago I'd probably be excited
for that more than I am now the fact
that it's the next chapter and Laurie
Strode Michael Myers story that they're
saying is the official chapter I am
interested there's the part where Laurie
Strode granddaughter is talking with her
friends they're like we heard your
grandma on Michael Myers a brother and
sister and she's like now that was just
a rumor someone made out so it looks
like they're retconning that plotline
Laurie Strode and Michael Meyers are not
brother and sister because that plot
line was actually made in Halloween - in
Halloween - now didn't happen or they
our brother and sister is gonna be the
big reveal in this movie which was the
big reveal and another Halloween movie
that didn't happen so I guess that's the
difference between Halloween h2o in this
one Halloween h2o scrapped everything
after Halloween - but cap Tala weaned -
this one scraps everything after one
eliminating Halloween - so at that point
if they're not brother and sister you
can ask like why is Michael Myers coming
after her why does he care I suppose the
answer is something akin to why do we
need this movie why do people care
because unfinished work needs and ending
it needs closure Laurie Strode has been
prepping for this moment - there's all
these mannequins she just shoots them
with his gun so yeah Michael bring your
knife to my gunfight there are a couple
of cool moments in this trailer though
let's see where she sees him in the
window and shoots it's actually a mirror
also that scene at the very end of the
trailer the kids like can you close the
closet and the closet door won't close
and this girl opens it up and as Michael
Myers in there boogeyman in the closet
that's a primal childhood fear we see it
embodied here we see it happen it's
actually quite violating I think doesn't
it yeah I'm gonna give this movie a shot
like I said I've been in this scenario
before Halloween h2o is literally the
same promise this movie is making and if
they do just this movie to give us an
end cap to Halloween and Halloween I'm
totally cool with that I hope they're
not trying to be like alright now we'll
make more it'll be a hundred and fifty
and still killing people not everything
needs to be a franchise sometimes you
can just you can do it to end the work
nothing wrong with that but we'll see
how it goes alright so the trailer to
Halloween which is actually Halloween -
but Halloween - didn't happen so this is
a new Halloween - that's called
Halloween like the original Halloween
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]